"Blue Bloods" is a ratings powerhouse for CBS,
but some of the show's nine-million average
weekly watchers are speaking out about the rapid
decline of a fan-favorite character. Here's why.
No TV show is perfect, especially if it's been
on the air for 10-plus seasons. Plot holes and
logic gaps tend to form, irking eagle-eyed
fans. Popular characters are diminished,
or just get annoying, after being
mishandled in the writers' room.
That's evidently the case with CBS's
police procedural "Blue Bloods" right now,
as some fans are clearly fed up
with one character in particular.
Husband and wife cop team Officer Jamie
Reagan (played by Will Estes) and Officer
Edit "Eddie" Janko-Reagan (played by
Vanessa Ray) work well together as
partners on the force, largely
because of their differences.
While Jamie is even-tempered and gentle-hearted,
Eddie is passionate, with strong opinions. This
contrast helps them balance each other
out in their progressing relationship,
as well as on patrol as part of the
New York City Police Department.
Ray joined the series in the fourth season,
and was instantly attracted to the character's
personality. She told Nerds of Color in 2021,
"She was eager, messy, and flawed.
I mean, who wouldn't love Eddie?"
Eddie isn't perfect, but her
honesty brings a different and
welcome energy to the long-running
family-slash-police drama. However,
some "Blue Bloods" fans are definitely
not happy with her personality as of late.
In the recent Season 13 episode, "Past
History," Eddie tries to play matchmaker
with Assistant District Attorney Erin
Reagan, who is Eddie's sister-in-law,
and Erin's criminal defense
attorney ex-husband, Jack Boyle,
during a case. This storyline didn't
exactly sit well with longtime viewers.
"So you're helping out Defense Attorneys now?"
"Yeah, aren't you supposed to
be on the Prosecutor's side?"
Some fans felt Eddie overstepped her
boundaries with the Reagan family
overall, especially its police commissioner
patriarch, Frank Reagan. One viewer tweeted,
"Eddie crossed so many lines. [She's]
gonna need to talk to Frank too."
Yes, Eddie wants her sister-in-law to
be happy. But she's clearly inserting
herself into Erin's private business when
she has no right to. Also, Eddie had a
similar conversation with Erin years ago about
Jack, so why would she try this tact again?
One fan noted this on the "Blue
Bloods" subreddit, writing,
"Erin and Eddie's behavior was
in character, but I thought Eddie
recruiting Jack for the purpose of getting
him and Erin back together was stupid."
Fans generally seem fed up with Eddie and
how recent scripts treat her character,
an issue that especially pops up in the
later seasons. Another fan on Reddit posted,
"Why do they write Eddie as so
immature? She is a grown woman
near 40 and they have her talk and
act like a naive teenager sometimes."
"I wanna work wherever you work."
"Eddie, we can't work together our whole career."
"Why not?"
Another fan noticed something
similar, posting on Twitter,
"Why has ['Blue Bloods'] made the
Eddie character so difficult lately?"
In the Season 13 episode "First Blush," Eddie
not only lashes out at her husband over his
transfer to another precinct, she mouths
off at her superior officer too. The user
wondered if the show's writers were trying
to make the character unlikeable on purpose.
Before being on the receiving end
of so much criticism, Vanessa Ray
said she admires her character's strength and
resourcefulness. She told Nerds of Color in 2021,
"I hope that Eddie showcases that
gut instinct that women have. The
deep knowing that forces us into action."
"Blue Bloods" is currently the fourth most-watched
show on broadcast television, according to
Deadline. Fans can chart Eddie's evolution –
or devolution – Fridays at 10/9 Central on CBS.